I have a friend who wakes around 3 to 4
a.m. for about an hour then goes back to
sleep she has suffered some trauma and
anxiety I'm aware that some cultures may
different sleep patterns what could be
going on here and it'll extend the
question in the private Q&A so we don't
want to just touch on this a little bit
and then probably we'll come back to it
yeah it sounds like a very normal
pattern actually exactly I'm that yet a
unbroken night of sleep is an unusual
thing and perhaps not the healthiest
thing there is something to be said for
a break in the middle it's very common
that people who have good good sleep
cycles do this and insofar as it's been
looked at by anthropologists many
hunter-gatherer societies and I actually
don't know if there are exceptions to
this I just don't know how many
anthropologists have looked specifically
at sleep cycles but several and I can't
recall at the moment which which people
which peoples do exactly this it's
nearly not quite so late in the night
but you know sitting around a snare and
a fire yeah go to bed sleep for three or
four hours and then get up and actually
do some some work or just conversation
which is a kind of work in many cases
for an hour or two and then go back to
sleep for another three or four hours
and this also apparently is known from
some era in second millennial Europe I
can't remember exactly what I do not
know my sort of Medieval and Renaissance
and enlightenment European history very
well but there's some evidence that many
people were doing that then whenever
that exactly then was yep now I find on
a related note that if I am sleeping and
I wake up in the middle of the night and
I make contact with the clock now this
is obviously not a natural pattern but
if I figure out what time it is in the
middle of the night and there's a bunch
of hours left to sleep having gone to
sleep again having seen the clock I tend
to wake up at exactly the right moment
so I'm at the right place in my sleep
cycle and that probably has a huge
positive impact on all sorts of things
waking up in the middle of your sleep
cycle because your alarm clock suddenly
decided you should be out of bed is at
least very stressful it's it's so
damaging so
that would have been perfectly possible
to do under some but not all
circumstances in pre-industrial era
where even if you were not sleeping
outside you could easily go outside and
look at the moon the position the moon
and so this requires that you not only
know what the phase of the moon is but
what that phase means about where the
moon will be in the sky and you can't do
it as reliably the closer to new it is
but you know given the full moon rises
approximately at sundown depending on
how close you are to the equator and you
know Rises an hour-ish later every every
night as it wanes and approaches again
rising around sundown as it approaches
fall if you know that you know that all
sounded like a lot of words and how
would you exactly form a model of that
well of course she would anyone who
spent a lot of time outside you know
doing say research in Madagascar or
backpacking or just you know in the
backcountry comes to understand these
patterns and you internalize it and it
is a clock it's not doesn't have the
precision of a clock but it is a clock
yep and they're also I'm so sorry yeah
it won't work around the new moon it
won't work with cloud cover right really
right
there's also in every place on earth
local patterns which you couldn't
globalize can say this is the pattern
but they're things that you learn if
you're there sounds of birds and insects
and such yeah when I was working on bats
when I was radio tracking active bats
you go out at night you're up all night
and the sounds are very different at
dawn and at dusk and in the middle of
the night and you know you would have
some idea how many hours had passed
based on on what you were hearing and
then like I mean like in every place
that I've been in the tropics where you
know I'm particularly attuned to the
frog calls that you know well I have
focused on the diurnal frogs the
nocturnal frogs are much more common but
two in the morning there's very little
frog call that the so called nocturnal
frogs tend to start calling around dusk
and they and so near the tropics you
call it basically 6 a.m. to 6 p.m. is
daytime so they'll start calling around
6 p.m. or so by midnight they're pretty
much done and then you'll start hearing
maybe some of them again around 5 a.m.
or so so if you wake up and there's no
for alcohol at all you know at least
you're sort of in the middle of the
night and that in the depth of the night
yeah
[Music]